اسرار الكون وعالم الفضاء يكشفها برنامج
الفوازير ما وراء الكواكب في اطار من
العلوم والمعرفه والترفيه
العامه عن علوم الفضاء ويقدمها بشكل عصري
وقد تولت وكاله الفضاء ناسا البحرين
التواصل مع وكالات ناسا في العالم للتاكيد
المعلومات المطروحه 30 حلقه ستاخذ الطفل
في رحله بين الكواكب تسلط الضوء على علماء
الفلك المسلمين تعرض على منصه شاهد وامبيز
ام بي سي ام بي سي 3 في رمضان الحالي جاء
بالتعاون مع مركز ايادي المستقبل ووكاله
نازل البحرين البحرين ومن اشراف هناء
الشهري واخراج ايناس يعقوب ومن البحرين
ينضم الينا الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه
الوطنيه لعلوم الفضاء الدكتور محمد
العسيري دكتور محمد شكرا لانضمامك الينا
بدايه اريد اسالك عن ناسا البحرين يعني ما
هي المهام الرئيسيه لوكاله ناسا البحرين
ومدى متى تاسستها كم سنه يعني
ونصبح عليكم بالخير طبعا الهيئه الوطنيه
لعلوم الفضاء او باختصارا ان اس اس اي
مملكه البحرين تاسست في عام 2014 بمرسوم
ملكي من قبل سيدي حضر صاحب الجلاله الملك
المعظم مهمه الرئيسيه العمل على وضع اسم
البحرين في مسافه الدول الرائده في مجال
الفضاء ولديها كثير من المشاريع وكذلك
بناء القدرات الوطنيه في مجال الفضاء
وعلومه
وتطبيقاته نعم دكتور محمد دواد ان نعرف ما
هي كواليس هذا العمل او هذا الوثائقي يعني
حابين نعرف مش بس وراء الكواكب ولكن وراء
هذا العمل طريقه تحضير هذا الوثائقي
طبعا العمل متميز من بدايه تفاهمنا مع
المخرجه ايناس يعقوب كان هناك تفاهم
لتوفير الدعم العلمي والمراجعه العلميه
للمحتوى الذي سيقدم من خلاله العمل
وبناء على هذا التعاون والذي اسس على
الناحيه علميه في وجهه نظري كانت لدينا
نحن رقبه شديده للتعاون وذلك لان احد
اهداف الهيئه وخطات الاستراتيجيه ان يكون
للهيئه دور في التوعيه باهميه الفضاء
وعلومه والتطبيقاته وخصوصا ما بين الجيل
الشباب والناشي او الاطفال
وعملنا مع المخرجه ايناس على وضع
نصوص مبسطه وواضحه وسهله الفهم لمختلف
الاعمار وكذلك
العمل على ان يكون العمل متميز
ومشوق في ذات الوقت ويتناسب مع فتره بثه
خلال شهر رمضان الفضيل
اللي واجهتكم دكتور في هذا العمل يعني
بالتاكيد العديد من البحوث والتحضير بس ما
هي كانت اصعب التحديات وكيف تجاوزتوها
بفضل الله يعني التحديات كانت البحث عن
المعلومه والتحري الدقه فيها لتقديمها
للمشاهدين الكرام بشكل لائق وصحيح وسليم
لانه جزء من بناء الثقافه الشخصيه
للمشاهدين ولكن الحمد لله المعلومات
متوفره
فريق المعني في الهيئه الوطنيه لعلم
الفضاء من المهندسين كانوا داعمين لهذا
المشروع
وكانوا يبدلون الجهد للحصول على المعلومه
والتاكد منها من اكثر من مصدر لضمان سلامه
وكذلك سياقه النصوص بشركه بشكل سلس لانه
كتابه النصوص يتطلب مهاره واعتقد الفريق
العامل مع الاستاذه ايناس كان على قدر
كبير من الامكانيه في صياغه النصوص ووضع
كافه لمسات على هذا العمل
دكتور شاهدنا مؤخرا السنين الفائته كيف
مقدم العلم في الفضاء عربيا خليجيا وعربيا
اين هو او اين وصل علم الفضاء خليجيا
وعربيا اليوم
لله الحمد تفضلت في السنوات الاخيره هنالك
تميز على مستوى العربي في هذا الجانب
والمستوى الدولي كذلك يعني اليوم احنا
نفخر بوصول مسبار الامل
كممثل دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
اضافه الى انه ممثل لكافه العرب الى
المريخ كذلك ننتظر خلال اسابيع وصول
المستكشف راشد كذلك على سطح القمر الجهود
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ضخمه جدا وكبيره
وسباقه في هذا المجال تاريخها يعود الى
نهايه الستينيات القرن الماضي والكفاءات
في المملكه وكذلك في دوله الامارات كثيره
وفي كافه المجالات واحنا في البحرين
الحارثين كذلك على التميز لدينا الكثير من
الابحاث عريصين على النشر العلمي على
استقلال البيانات والصور الفضائيه اليوم
في المنطقه لدعم صناعه القرار نعم الدكتور
التنفيذي للهيئه الوطنيه لعلوم الفضاء
الدكتور محمد العسيري شكرا لوجودك معنا
اليوم